Laurie Myers was born in 1961 as the youngest
of three children after her
siblings Judith and Michael.
When Laurie was just two
years old on October 31st,
1963, Mr. and Mrs. Myers went out for the
evening and Judith, 15-years old at the time,
was spending the night with her boyfriend.
Michael was left in the care of an older woman
named Mrs. Blankenship on their street.
We don’t know exactly where Laurie was,
but I would assume that she was also left
with Mrs. Blankenship, but given her age, was
probably already in bed when Michael snuck out,
grabbed a knife and stuck it into Judith 9 times.
To learn how Laurie’s suppressed
childhood memories may have come back
to save her in the end, that's
a subversion of expectations,
stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
(metal intro)
Welcome to Horror Historyyyyyy. In today’s lesson,
I am analyzing an innocent teenage girl whose
biological sibling becomes the most renowned
killer to ever pick up a knife. There are many
versions of this character because there are many
alternate timelines in the Halloween story.
Most Lauries represent different scenarios branching
off of Halloween night in 1978 -- the events of
the original Halloween movie. If you’ve seen
me cover other Halloween franchise characters,
you already know about the Halloween
Express, the train map that I use as
an analogy for the Halloween timeline.
In this video, I’ll be analyzing the
original timeline where Laurie is played by
Jaime Lee Curtis while she was in her 20s.
There may be other videos where we ride the
Halloween Express down alternate routes. But
for now, let’s take a look at Laurie Strode’s
first appearance in the Halloween franchise.
(spooky music)
What would you do if the boogeyman
haunting your town was your brother,
stalking your every move? Would you
hide under your cover? Would you run
away to parts unknown? Would you say,
“Ehh, at least he doesn’t talk a lot.”
Laurie lost her sister without ever really
knowing her at 2 years old. In a way,
she lost her brother too, because he was deemed
mentally unfit for society and placed in a
sanitarium. It would seem Laurie was taken to visit him at some point. I say this,
because she later recalls a memory of what
appears to be Michael at the sanitarium,
but for now, this memory is essentially buried.
A couple years later, in 1965, her parents
were killed in a car accident and Laurie was
placed in the foster care system. Soon after
she was adopted by the Strode family, where
her new father figure was a realtor. Being the
last remaining survivor of a pair of tragedies…
outside of her now institutionalized brother…
got the attention of the governor of Illinois,
who realized she was still young enough to
maybe have a normal life. He saw to it that
her name was changed and her file was sealed
so no one could connect her with Michael.
For some time, it seemed to have worked.
Laurie has completely forgotten about
her early life and is living
as if it has never happened.
Her foster-parents don’t give her
any information about her youth.
- [Young Laurie] Why won’t youever tell me anything?
- [Mrs. Strode] I told you, I’m not your mother.
– [Zac] Did these memories fade as all early memories
do, or were they repressed for her own protection?
We first meet Laurie Strode in her teenage
years, as a kind-hearted student focusing on
her grades and her work as a babysitter more
than her social life. Unlike her friends,
she is more of an introvert, though
her babysitting does make her a lot
of contacts in the Haddonfield community
like Doyles with their son Tommy, and the
Carruthers where she babysits a young Rachel.
She seems to have a connection with these kids,
almost like she is so innocent that she prefers
their company to the kids that are her own age.
- [Annie] It's tragic. You never
go out. You must have a small
fortune stashed from baby-sitting so much.
- [Laurie] The guys think I'm too smart.
– This aspect of her character would
potentially play a role in her survival.
On the morning of Halloween in 1978,
Mr. Strode asks her to drop off a key at a
house that he’s selling, which happens to be
the Myers house, the same house that fifteen
years before she would have called her home.
I think his confidence to send her there on a
casual errand speaks volumes to how everybody
felt she had fully recovered. She seems as
unafraid of this house as anyone in Haddonfield.
While in class that afternoon, Laurie
seems bored and stares out the window,
but what she finds is more disturbing than
she probably was expecting. Staring back at
her across the street is a man with a white
mask and brown car. The teacher distracts
her with a question and by the time she looks
back across the street, the man has vanished.
Laurie looks confused, perhaps wondering if
her imagination was playing a Halloween trick.
While walking home with her friends that
afternoon, Laurie spots the brown car again,
now driving up behind them. Her friends think it’s
a guy from their school but Laurie is not so sure.
Further ahead, she sees the man disappear behind
some hedges. Her friend Annie investigates, but
he’s gone before she gets there. Annie believes
that it’s a boy that has a crush on Laurie.
– Poor Laurie... Looks like you scared another one away.
– Wait, she’s done this before?
Upon getting home, she notices the masked man
standing in her neighbor’s yard just staring at
her from behind the clothesline. He mysteriously
vanishes once again. We can see she’s getting
pretty freaked out by these encounters.
Meanwhile, most of the other high schoolers
in Haddonfield are freaking over something else:
the Homecoming dance taking place the next night.
Laurie and Annie discuss it on the way to
their babysitting jobs, and Laurie admits
she’s interested in a classmate named Ben Tramer,
but doesn’t feel she has the courage to ask him
out. And can you blame her? Ben would literally
become the hottest guy in town that evening.
(tires screeching)
(explosion)
Later that night, while she’s babysitting
Tommy Doyle, Annie shows up and drops off
Lindsey Wallace, the child she had been
babysitting, if you want to call it that,
across the street. There was an unspoken agreement
between the two friends, so that Annie could have
some alone time with her boyfriend Paul. This
was the last time Annie was ever seen...alive.
There’s a clear split in priorities when
it comes to Laurie and her friends. They
are obsessed with hooking up, even if it means
letting their grades, and responsibilities slip,
while Laurie makes an effort to do everything
right. She does her homework and she plans
out activities for the kids she watches.
She even kind of looks after her friends,
as we would see later on. For these reasons, when
something isn’t right, Laurie is going to notice
it before Annie or Lynda might have. And
that might just be what keeps her alive.
Throughout the evening, Tommy keeps
asking Laurie about the boogeyman,
a legend told to him by his fellow classmates
to try to scare him. She dismisses his concerns
though, probably having heard the same
stories when she was in elementary school.
After putting the kids to bed, she receives a
weird phone call from her friend Lynda who was
also at the Wallace’s across the street.
What she heard on the other line at first
seemed like cries of passion, but the more
she hears, the more concerned she becomes.
She goes to check on the kids and
they are fast asleep which gives
her time to head across the street to
see what’s up. No one answers the door,
but she goes around back and
finds the back door left ajar.
She searches the seemingly empty house,
but no amount of urban legends could have
prepared her for what she would find.
(door creaking)
(cinematic impact)
Some of you who are old... BOOMERS may remember
the Halloween novelizations. These were books
created for fans that couldn't get enough
Halloween from the films. They offer a little more
background information about the characters and
some additional scenes and lore. Well, as it turns
out... with new Halloween movies out, they're
back! And you can experience them on Audible.
Audible offers an incredible selection of
audiobooks across every genre — including
horror. You’ll also discover exclusive
Audible Originals from top celebrities,
renowned experts, and
exciting new voices in audio.
Members get a free title every month, for keeps.
Plus, there's a great selection of free podcasts.
This month I have to admit, I am still
listening to Salem's Lot. I've been BUSY ok?
Making that Scream 3 video just decimated my
sleep schedule, and I was just like a vegetable.
I couldn't even really listen to an audiobook. But
I still did make some progress, and if I didn't
have Audible, then I probably would have made no progress, so
if you're busy like me, it really is perfect.
To try out Audible Premium Plus free
for 30 days visit audible.com/czworld
or text czsworld to 500-500. You'll
find that link written in blood on your
mirror. Audible.com/czsworld
(dark music)
In a bedroom upstairs her friend Annie
is arranged under the tombstone of Judith
Myers. Soonafter, she comes across
the remains of Lynda and Bob as well.
Stricken and emotionally shattered by what
she just found, Laurie runs out of the room
to find her worst nightmare waiting for
her. Michael stabs in her direction with a
kitchen knife and in her terror, she falls
over the railing onto the stairs below.
She hobbles as fast as she can to get out of the
house and tries to get help from the neighbors,
who probably assume she’s
playing a Halloween trick,
and shut her out. It also didn’t help that
she left the door locked without the keys
and she had to chuck a flower pot at the
window to wake up Tommy up to let her in.
Mmmmaybe it’s a good thing Michael Myers chose
to carve up Haddonfield that night. It would
not have been a look if Tommy’s parents came
home to find Laurie locked out of the house
she’s supposed to be watching, and Tommy sleeping
upstairs in a bed with some girl on their block.
Laurie sends Tommy back upstairs, turns out
the lights, and tries to contact someone
to help, but finds the phone lines have been cut.
Panic sets in when she realizes one of the
downstairs windows has been left open. I don’t
think she gets enough credit for what she does
next. While pretending to plead for her life,
she also stealthily arms herself with the
best weapon in the room, her knitting needle.
When Michael nearly impales her again,
after popping out from behind the couch,
she takes a swing of her own,
sticking him in the neck with it.
Not yet knowing who or what her attacker is,
she actually believes that this killed him,
which actually makes her behaviour even more
impressive. I think most people would be a mess
if they believed they just murdered someone, and
although she’s clearly shaken by the encounter,
she keeps her head together enough to remember
her main priority: protecting Tommy and Lindsey.
To her shock and terror Michael is
alive and now closing in on them,
but even under this unimaginable amount of
panic, she still does everything right, as she
orders the kids to hide themselves in
a closet as she goes to the bedroom,
and opens the patio door before taking cover
another closet. I think she does this to make it
look like she’d climbed out onto the roof for
help, it’s a nice idea, but it doesn’t work.
When Michael finds Laurie, she showcases
her resourcefulness by poking him in the
eye with a wire hanger, causing him to drop
his knife. I honestly can’t believe that
works. Every time I watch it, it’s just like
how does she get the thing to stay straight
enough to go into his eye? I maybe would have
gone for one of those wooden shades instead,
but what can I say? It worked out for her.
She retrieves Tommy and Lindsey from their hiding
place and tells them to run down the block for help.
– Go do as I say.
– She may be shy with her school crush,
but she's certainly capable of becoming
authoritative when the occasion calls for it.
However, this puts her in a bad position because
she's caught off guard by Michael yet again. He
strangles her with his bare hands, and in an
act of desperation, she rips off his mask.
I'm not going to try to analyze this as a
strategic move by Laurie because I think
it's pretty clear that it was just instinct. I
think a lot of horror fans like to paint
her as this rarity, like she's one of the
smart ones. But between forgetting her keys,
leaving the knife behind and turning her back
to the guy that's trying to slice her up,
this probably isn't a test that she'd be
posting up on her fridge. She's passing
but not with flying colors, and not
without a little bit of luck as well.
And this was her luckiest moment, because when
she pulls off Michael's mask, a gunshot rings
out from the darkness and a man in a trench
coat, who we know as Dr. Samuel Loomis,
shoots Michael several times knocking him
off of the balcony and saving Laurie's life.
He tells her that that was, in fact, the
boogeyman and she breaks down into tears.
Between the cuts she received from Michael
and her physical and mental exhaustion
from that night’s events, they actually
have to take her away on a stretcher and
in the ambo, she’s very adamant
about not being put to sleep.
– Don’t let them put me to sleep.
– After arriving at Haddonfield Memorial Hospital,
she is again adamant with the Dr. that she not
be sedated. What is the reasoning for this? I
don’t think Laurie herself fully understands.
I think the desire not to go to sleep
is coming from her subconscious mind.
Earlier, I discussed how she was able to suppress
her childhood memories about what happened to her
family in the mid 1960s. This was basically done
as a defense mechanism so that she could go back
to living a semi-normal life without constantly
being reminded of those painful memories. She
didn’t do this on purpose, it was just her
subconscious brain trying to protect her.
I should note that in real life, the idea of
repressed memories, or as the American Psychiatric
Association puts it: “dissociative amnesia”
is not commonly accepted as a real phenomenon,
but since we’re in the world of Halloween and not
the real world, I’m willing to look past that.
So Laurie didn’t want to go to sleep because
those harmful memories had to go somewhere,
and some part of her realized that
it was her dreams where the truth
was hidden. Dr. Mixter ignores her
request however, and sedates her.
When she came to, she would receive some horrifying information,
making her experiences to that point seem that much scarier.
(big impact)
(mysterious music)
Laurie wakes up to a hospital employee named Jimmy who
fills her in on who her mysterious attacker was.
She recognizes the name in relation to the
Myers house, but does not understand why
Michael has chosen her to hunt. Jimmy is kicked
out by the charge nurse who tells Laurie that
they’re having trouble getting in contact with
her parents because the phones are not working.
As the clock creeps into the earliest part of
November, Laurie eventually succumbs to her
exhaustion and falls asleep. Sure enough, she
dreams of some creepy memories from her youth,
including her foster-mother refusing to tell her
about her past and a strange, yet familiar boy
looking out a window. I think her brain
is slowly putting together the pieces
about who this forgotten boy is, because her
experience that evening, in particular, the moment
where she tore off Michael’s mask, is slowly
kicking that part of her brain back into gear.
On some level, she seems terrified by this, and
not wanting to dig into her past any further,
she does everything she can to
stay awake, eventually resulting
in her just sleeping with her eyes wide
open which concerns the medical staff.
Eventually, Laurie wakes up. I’m guessing it’s
right here while this nurse is investigating a
disturbance outside. Between that, and the
cut phone lines, I guess she realized that
something was up at this hospital, and that
maybe she hadn’t evaded the danger quite yet.
She sets up a decoy in her bed using pillows
-- and can we just pause for a second?
Why is this a movie trope? I talked about this
exact same trap when I covered Andy Barclay from
Child’s Play. I guess the idea is that the bad
guy will come in, see this lump under the bed,
and then go attack that instead of immediately
going to find his victim. But what does that
save you, like 2 seconds? You’re better off
not taking the time to set up the decoy.
Anyway, this leads to her wandering the halls
in a dazed state, trying to get her hands
on a working phone to no avail. She collapses
in a ball on the floor, and we’re just forced
to sit there for 22 seconds watching her
fall asleep, this goes on way too long.
Eventually, Laurie gets back to her feet,
still in a bit of a drugged up state,
and the nurse tries to come get her,
and Laurie turns just in time to see
Michael Myers stab her in the back with
a scalpel. And this is Laurie’s reaction.
She hobbles away in the slowest chase ever.
Laurie is slowed by her injuries and sedatives,
and Michael is just a slow walker, that’s how he
is. She ends up barely, and I mean, barely evading
him behind a closing elevator door. Some people
really will do anything to avoid using the stairs.
Anyway, Laurie hides in random car,
which turns out to be Jimmy’s car,
but it won’t start because the fuel line has
been cut, and he also collapses onto the horn,
drawing Michael’s attention back to them.
She does, however, see a possible chance to
get to safety when, Dr. Loomis pulls up with
a state marshal. She tries calling out for
help but when she screams, she’s not able to
produce enough sound to get their attention.
When I did the Horror History episode
on Laurie’s daughter, Jamie Lloyd,
I talked about how she, at one point, suffered
from a condition known as selective mutism,
rendering her unable to speak. As it turns out,
this condition can be brought on by a number
of factors, and genetic makeup is one of them.
Laurie’s inability to speak only lasts a few
moments, but given that her brother Michael
stopped speaking after his traumatic event on Halloween
and her eventual daughter Jamie lost her voice
for a year under similar circumstances, that
could be the reason that she’s not able to
call for help. It also fits in with the theme of
dreams and nightmares present in Halloween II,
which I talk more about in this
episode of Things You Missed.
Laurie is chased by Michael again, and
Dr. Loomis eventually lets her in just
before Michael comes crashing through the door.
Loomis shoots him down, but at this point,
his ability rise back up and give chase is
no surprise to either of them. They
find shelter in an empty operating
room. Loomis tries handing Laurie his
gun but she is hesitant to take it.
– [Loomis] C’mon, c’mon, c’mon.
– No.
– Take it.
– You would think in a life or
death situation like this,
she would want to arm herself. We’ve already
seen she has no problem fighting back,
based on her actions earlier that
night, so what’s going on here?
This could go back to the
innocence of her character,
but it may also be the realization dawning
on her that the Michael Myers before her is
the very same boy seen staring out the
window in her dreams, her own brother.
Michael stabs Loomis and turns his attention
to Laurie, who comes to her senses and shoots
him in the face -- temporarily blinding him.
While he is hopelessly slashing at the air,
she sees Dr. Loomis opening the
compressed gas canisters in the room.
Realizing that he’s being lured
away by the sound, she follows suit,
which makes it harder for him to track
them using the sound of their movements.
After receiving the word from Loomis, she
runs out of the room and down the hall,
when she feels the room she left behind
explode and knock her off of her feet.
(explosion)
When Laurie turns to look at the blaze, to
her absolute horror, a burning figure is walking
towards her. Laurie doesn’t even move when she
sees this, almost as if she’s given up the fight.
If stabbing him, poking his eye out, shooting
him 13 times, and blowing him up was not enough
to stop him, maybe Michael just could not
be defeated. However, that would be as far
as he would go, as Laurie watches him
collapse face first for the final time.
Emergency services show up at the scene that
morning to put out the fire and rescue her. She
is wheeled out of the hospital to yet another
ambulance. News crews try to speak with her,
but she basically gives them the Marshawn Lynch
treatment, and refuses to speak with the media.
She asks to sit in the front,
perhaps not wanting to relive
any part of the journey she had just been through.
All in all, Laurie Strode was traumatized
by that evening's events. She discovered
the deaths of three of her friends, nearly
lost her own life, witnessed the murder of
a nurse and played a part in an explosion that
all but killed two people. I’m sure any thoughts
of attending that Homecoming dance were already out
the window at this point, as she would probably be
spending the next 24 hours in another hospital,
but she would later discover that Ben Tramer,
the boy she was interested in attending the dance
with, had also been killed that Halloween night.
Maybe it is because Laurie has dealt with
tragedy her entire life, but she actually
moves on pretty quickly from Ben Tramer, and
ends up getting together with a man named Mr.
Lloyd almost immediately. There is a popular
fan theory that Mr. Lloyd is actually Jimmy,
because we never learn his last name,
he seems to be interested in her,
and the two share a bond in having
gone through the most terrifying
night ever together, but I can neither
confirm or deny that he is Mr Lloyd.
It’s only a little over a year later that
she becomes pregnant with their child,
and in either late 1980 or early 1981, she
gives birth to a daughter named Jamie. I
think her name goes against the whole “Jimmy
is Mr. Lloyd” theory, just because it would
be confusing having a household
consisting of Jimmy and Jamie.
But if that is the case, it would not have been
a problem for very long, because in November
of 1987, Laurie and Jamie’s father get into a
fatal car accident, just like Laurie’s parents
before her. We don’t know much about those
final years leading up to Laurie’s death,
but it at least seems as if her and Jamie’s father
had a good relationship with their daughter.
– I know you miss your parents,
it hasn’t been that long.
– It’s been 11 months.
– [Zac] Jamie is left with a shoebox containing
photos of her mom when she was younger,
and curiously, a photo of Michael as well,
perhaps suggesting that Laurie did
teach her about her dark family history.
If you want to see me speculate further about
Laurie and Jamie’s limited time together,
you’ll want to watch Jamie’s episode of Horror
History, which you can find by clicking that
video on the left. Remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week,
RING the deathbell for ALL notifications, and I’ll
see you in the next one. Assuming we both survive.
(rock music)